وسنبدا بمعتز بالله حسن في كهرمان مرش
مركز الزلزال وكيف يتطور المشهد هناك معتز
تعجز الكلمات عن الوصف هذا هو المشهد خلفي
قبل قليل اخرجت بعض الجثث من هذا المكان
وها هي حاله حاله من الالم حاله من الحزن
في هذا المكان جراء
جراء ما حدث طبعا ليس امرا سهلا انتظار
عده ايام
نحن الان في اليوم الرابع من منذ ضرب هذا
الزلزال 10 محافظات تركيا وما خلفه من
قتلى وجرحى بحسب السلطات الرسميه عدد
القتلى يزيد على 16 الف قتيل واكثر من 60
الف جريح هذا هو المشهد هنا في كهرمان
مراش مركز الزلزال
الى اليوم كانوا ما يزالوا يحاولون ان
يقوموا بنقل هذه
محاوله انقاذي الناس من تحت الالقاد ولكن
الوضع فعلا صعب اكثر من ثلاثه جثث جثث
خرجت اليوم من هذا المكان
الذي كنا منذ الصباح نحاول ان نتابع فيه
اعمال الانقاذ طبعا المنظر صعب جدا لكن
ليس هذا الموقع فقط ننقل الكاميرا الى
الجزء الاخر هناك
كما تشاهدون ربما قد تصف الكاميرا الحال
المباني اينما وجهت وجهك في كهرمان مراش
الا المباني اما هي مدمره محطمه بالكامل
او هي متشققه وبالتالي لا يمكن العوده الى
هذه المباني الحال هو واحد في جميع المدن
التي ضربها الزلزال ولكن كهرمان مراش هي
فعلا تعاني بشكل كبير
الشوارع التي يفترض ان تكون هي مسار مريح
للسيارات اليوم هي السيارات لا تستطيع ان
تسير بشكل جيد سيارات الاطفاء الاسعاف
الشاحنات كل ذلك هو في حركه
يحاولون الوصول الى الاماكن ولكن من الصعب
من الصعب جدا التحرك في هذا المكان حاله
من الحزن حاله من
الانتظار حاله من القلق كل ذلك في هذه
المدينه التي شهدت
كتب لها ان تكون مركزا لزلزال كبير او
زلزالان شدتهما اكثر من سبع سبع فاصله ست
درجات وسبعه فاصل سبعه درجات
[موسيقى]
اعداديه الكبيره والكثيره التي تحدث في ظل
اوضاع الابنيه في تلك المنطقه
[موسيقى]
هو وضع صعب طبعا وانا اتحدث سياره نقل
موتى تحاول الخروج من المكان هنا
همم وضع الهزات الارداديه هو وضع صعب جدا
لان المباني في معظمها هي مباني ايلا
للسقوط ومع اي هزه ارتداديه او زلزال حتى
لو كان خفيفا فان هذه المباني قد تكون
فخا لمن يعمل بجانبها او لمن عمال القاده
الذين يكونون يعملون في الجانب الاخر
وبالتالي الوضع في كهرمان مراش هو ربما
يمثل الوضع في مدينه انطاكيا يمثل وضع في
المدن الاخرى مثل القضيمان موضوع الهزات
الارتداديه سجل اكثر من 1113 هزه بحسب
السلطات هنا في تركيا وهذا عدد كبير من
الهزات بعض المباني اخبرنا المهندسون انه
في حال كانت الهزه ما بين ثلاثه الى اربع
درجات قد يسقط المبنى الى هذه الدرجه
الوضع صعب في مدن ككهان مرعش طيب المعتز
ماذا عن الناجين الذين فقدوا بيوتهم في
تلك المنطقه خصوصا في ظل جهود السلطات
التركيه لتامين مراكز ايواء وماوى لهم كيف
يمكن وصف حاله هؤلاء
[موسيقى]
في الزلازل السابقه كان من الممكن التامين
هؤلاء الاشخاص بس لان جهد الدوله كان كله
يتجه نحو مدينه واحده يعني مثلا في زلزال
الى زلزال فان هذا ما شاهدناه كان هناك
محاوله لاسكان الناس في ذلك المكان
وكان ذلك امرا قد يكون سهلا لكن اليوم نحن
نتحدث على عده محافظات وفي عده محافظات
الزلزال ضربه اماكن واسعه جدا موضوع
الاسكان حاليا هو كما وعد الرئيس ربما
يقول هو انه خلال سنه سيتم العمل على
اسكان الناس لكن حاليا هناك بعض الخيام
التي قدمتها منظمه اداره الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه هناك بعض الخيام
ما يشابهها مما جاء في المساعده الدوليه
ولكن الوضع صعب فيما يتعلق باقامه عدد
كبير كهؤلاء الاشخاص الذين دمرت مباني
اكثر من 6000 مب في المحافظات العشر وهذا
رقم كبير جدا طيب وماذا ايضا عن بقيه
الخدمات في المدينه نحن نتحدث بعد ثلاثه
ايام على وقوع هذا الزلزال ماذا عن اوضاع
مثلا المواد الغذائيه الادويه وضع
المستشفيات كل ذلك كيف يبدو في المدينه
هناك روح تعاون واضحه في المكان سواء كان
ذلك من جهه الدوله الحكومه الناس العاديون
كلهم يحاولون التعاون من اجل
المضي هذه الايام بما يمكن ان يعين الناس
هناك مثلا عربات مخصصه للجيش عربات مخصصه
لمنظمه افات كلها تقدم الاطعمه هناك اشخاص
يجلبون الاطعمه هناك اشخاص يجلبون
البطانيات الملابس في ناحيه قريبه من هنا
هناك شاحنه كبيره جاءت ملابس ووضعت
هذه الملابس وطلب من الناس ان تختار ما
تشاء من اجل ان تتدفع روح التعاون موجوده
ولكن كل ذلك مع هبوط درجات الحراره في فصل
الشتاء ومع حجم الدمار الكبير قد لا يكون
كافيا هناك حاجه ماسه لجهد نوعي من اجل
تامين مكاني اقامه اكثر دفئا للناس
المتضررين